politics can be simple the libs want to
complicate everything the libs want to
pretend that nothing is clear at all we
can't ever know anything you can't even
know if a man is a man and a woman is a
woman it's all just you just need to
have 27 degrees from Harvard and then
maybe you can weigh in on basic
questions normal guy on the street knows
what a woman is Justice katanji Jackson
with multiple degrees from Harvard can't
tell you what a woman is random Joe on
the street knows that something's up
with the vaccine and with covid and he's
not going to rush to take an
experimental drug despite all the
promises from the federal government Dr
fauci he's got a thousand degrees he's
got the white lab coat he's he's so
smart and sophisticated now she's wrong
the regular guy is right politics can be
really simple stop the bad guys protect
the innocent there's another part here
which is really key it's not enough to
be right in politics there is no
substitute for victory